[Musica]
prendiamoci qualche istante per
esplorare queste immagini
avete vista
era molto affollata c'erano tantissimi
oggetti in quest'immagine
è chiaramente avrete la sensazione di
non essere riusciti proprio a coglierli
tutti è normale perché il nostro
cervello in ogni momento può elaborare
una quantità molto limitata dei segnali
che arrivano in ingresso e quindi in
ogni momento e necessario fare una
selezione una scelta qualcosa viene
selezionato e quindi possiamo elaborarlo
qualche modo è qualcos'altro invece
viene ignorato ed è quasi come se non
fosse mai esistito il meccanismo che
manovra questa scelta e l'attenzione
l'attenzione quindi è un meccanismo che
ci permette di fare ordine fa in modo
che solo una piccola parte tra tutte le
informazioni in entrata venga
selezionata venga elaborata in modo tale
che noi possiamo poi prenderne coscienza
e l'attenzione quindi che ci permette di
stabilire una connessione fra quello che
il nostro mondo interno la nostra mente
la nostra coscienza la nostra
consapevolezza e quello che l'ambiente
esterno con i suoi diversi ambienti
segnali richiami una volta che
l'attenzione ha selezionato determinati
oggetti
allora i nostri occhi possono muoversi
per portare a quegli oggetti al centro
del nostro sguardo così li possiamo
vedere bene e poi eventualmente se
necessario possiamo anche iniziare un
movimento per andare a raggiungere
questi oggetti
un argomento che si sta studiando molto
ancora a proposito proprio del
funzionamento dell'attenzione
riguarda il come avvenga questa scelta
c'è quali sono quei principi che
l'attenzione usa per decidere che cosa è
prioritario rispetto a quello che non lo
è beh diciamo che io lavoro da vent'anni
mai questo ambito ma non serve che ve lo
dica io perché vi rendiate conto che fra
tutte le immagini che c'erano ma in
questo in questo insieme è una che
probabilmente abbiamo visto tutti ed è
questa perché l'abbiamo vista tutti
perché era in movimento il nostro
cervello è fatto in modo per assegnare
una priorità più elevata ad oggetti che
si muovono rispetto a oggetti che sono
statici
altre immagini che noi probabilmente
abbiamo scorto all'interno di questo
insieme sono oggetti di colore rosso
perché non tanto per il fatto che siano
rossi ma perché dal momento in cui siamo
entrati in questo teatro ci siamo
guardati intorno abbiamo visto tanti
oggetti di questo colore anche l'insegna
telex e di colore rosso e quindi nella
nostra mente il concetto di rosso sia
attivato e quando è comparsa questa
immagine tutti i punti che contenevano
questo colore sono diventati diciamo
prioritari rispetto ad altri e quindi
possono aver portato la nostra
attenzione
verso questi oggetti
bene
sicuramente però avremo notato altri
elementi all'interno di questa immagine
ma da qui in poi se dovessimo fare una
lista di ciò che ha notato uno è ciò che
ho notato l'altro vedremo che la
sovrapposizione che le proprio a
diminuire perché ciascuno avrà notato
degli elementi diversi perché entra in
gioco la familiarità che ciascuno di noi
ha con determinati contesti determinati
oggetti il valore che noi attribuiamo a
quegli oggetti quindi per esempio ci
sarà chi è appassionato di sport che
avrà notato il fatto che c'era un
pallone da calcio ci sarà chi è
appassionato di musica che avrà notato
che c'era il pianista lo spartito
l'immagine di monteverdi
ci sarà chi è fumatore e magari avrà
notato che c'era un uomo che si
accendeva la sigaretta e quindi
la nostra esperienza precedente la
familiarità che noi abbiamo con questi
oggetti
guida è uno dei meccanismi che guidano
la nostra attenzione si dice no che noi
vediamo le cose non per come sono ma per
come siamo questa è una nozione che
nella saggezza popolare cioè da
centinaia di anni no
la scienza però ci ha messo un po per
poter arrivare a studiare questi
fenomeni con un rigore metodologico in
modo proprio sperimentale ed è stato
dimostrato proprio come l'esperienza
precedente le conoscenze già acquisite
le nostre abitudini
abbiano peso importante nel guidare la
nostra attenzione e quindi nel guidare
anche il modo in cui noi esploriamo
l'ambiente
di fronte a una stessa immagine tutti i
nostri cervelli hanno iniziato a operare
una selezione ma ci hanno portato ad
avere ciascuno una percezione un po
diversa rispetto a quella che ha avuto
il nostro compagno
è importante studiare come l'esperienza
guida l'attenzione perché
da un lato ci permette di capire come
funziona il nostro cervello
dall'altro però ha dei risvolti
applicativi molto interessanti che ha
qualche tipo di dipendenza per esempio
lo sa bene che quando entra in una
stanza per esempio un fumatore si
accorge subito involontariamente nota se
c'è un posacenere nelle vicinanze mentre
passeggia per la città involontariamente
proprio i suoi occhi cadono sull'insegna
di una tabaccheria
e questi segnali una volta che sono
stati rilevati sono fungere da
trampolino per far aumentare la voglia
magari di accendersi la sigaretta o far
nascere questa voglia che magari invece
non c'era prima e il problema di questi
automatismi e il fatto che non basta
smettere di fumare per non esserne più
vittima anzi spesso
dopo che la dipendenza di per sé è
sopita e vinta la permanenza di questi
automatismi che riguardano la nostra
attenzione è una delle cause che poi
portano alle ricadute
quindi capire come possono nascere sulla
base dell'esperienza precedente questi
automatismi può portare a capire come
fare per poterli dissolvere per
eliminarli
sapere come funziona l'attenzione in un
certo senso ci permette anche di
prevedere anticipare il nostro
comportamento è quello degli altri e
anche questo di per sé ha una grande
importanza da un punto di vista proprio
applicativo no
se pensiamo
ai meccanismi che guidano l'attenzione
di cui abbiamo parlato prima
soltanto in un contesto completamente
spoglio no completamente naturale questi
possono entrare in azione in maniera del
tutto spontanea
basta entrare in un ambiente delimitato
circoscritto per modificare il numero e
il tipo dei segnali che possono entrare
in gioco per guidare la nostra
attenzione e di fatto questo offre la
possibilità a qualcun altro di guidare
la nostra esplorazione dell'ambiente se
pensate per esempio le vetrine dei
negozi o le corsie dei supermercati
sono fatte in modo da far cadere il
nostro sguardo su determinati oggetti e
determinate insegne
la situazione proprio sì delimita più
chiaramente più nettamente quando del
mondo e tre dimensioni ci spostiamo a
quello a due dimensioni allo schermo di
un computer
chi progetta siti web per esempio oi
social oggigiorno
sfrutta moltissimo queste conoscenze che
si hanno sull'orientamento
dell'attenzione e addirittura sfruttano
anche l'esperienza precedente perché se
badate bene a ciascuno di noi ormai
viene offerta una serie di notizie e di
pubblicità per esempio di banner
pubblicitari che sono personalizzate
sulla base del nostro profilo
c'è traccia delle nostre esperienze
precedenti perché viene tenuto conto di
tutto ciò che noi abbiamo guardato ho
cliccato in precedenza
quindi la selezione che in teoria
dovremmo fare noi potremmo fare noi
spontaneamente ci arriva in questo caso
già preconfezionata lì se pensiamo tutte
queste cose nel loro complesso è
possibile quindi che un po per quella
che è la nostra tendenza naturale noi
siamo fatti così e un po per le
strategie che gli altri usano per
sfruttare questi questo nostro
funzionamento
noi ci troviamo a
esplorare le cose gli ambienti sempre
nello stesso modo siamo guidati sempre
dagli stessi segnali e questo rafforza
anche delle nostre abitudini si possono
rafforzare degli schemi non che si
alimentano continuamente e che vanno
benissimo
nel senso che ci permettono di essere
più efficienti ci permettono di perdere
meno tempo di estrarre dall'ambiente le
informazioni che ci servono in maniera
molto più veloce però d'altra parte se
questi comportamenti che si rinforzano
sono comportamenti che noi vorremmo
evitare questo non è certo desiderabile
nel caso del fumatore per esempio se è
una persona che vuole smettere di fumare
trovarsi a notare ogni volta qualche
segnale che fa venire voglia di fumare
non è certo l'ideale
come fare quindi per uscire da questi
automatismi quando non sono desiderati
non è semplice ci si sta ancora
lavorando molto e quindi non c'è ancora
una risposta chiara a questa a questa
domanda
una possibile strategia per passa
proprio attraverso quella che è la
nostra tendenza naturale a farci guidare
dall'esperienza precedente e dalle
conoscenze il nostro cervello
il nostro sistema nervoso ha una
capacità molto spiccata di plasmarsi
adattarsi rispetto all apprendimento no
quando arrivano delle informazioni nuove
quest e ci cambiano per sempre ogni
interazione che non abbiamo con
l'ambiente o con gli altri va a creare
una nuova memoria e questa nuova memoria
può essere usata proprio come
precedente un nuovo parametro che guida
la nostra attenzione e il nostro
comportamento in futuro quindi una
strategia possibile per interrompere
questi vecchi automatismi
può essere data dal fatto di crearne di
nuovi appositamente
sforzandoci insomma di alimentare nuove
conoscenze quindi di acquisire nuove
competenze di arricchire la nostra
conoscenza perché questo non solo ci
permette di aumentare quella che è la
nostra enciclopedia personale ma va
plasmare la lente attraverso la quale
noi vediamo e comprendiamo il mondo che
ci circonda ed è un potere che è nelle
nostre mani
voglio chiudere quindi lanciandogli una
piccola sfida ora di fronte a questa
immagine che ormai avete già visto
fate un favore alla vostra storia e al
vostro futuro e provate a guardare uno
degli aspetti che prima avevate
trascurato che non avevate considerato
così interessante e lasciate che questo
vi guidi verso nuove idee nuovi spunti e
sogni di cui capirete il senso solo
domani
[Applauso]